aller en face à l'actualité judiciaire à
présent marquée hier par l'audition de
salles abdeslam dans le procès des
attentats du 13 novembre 2015 le seul
membre des commandos encore en vie
étaient à la barre pour la première fois
depuis les attentats les précisions de
katia technique à la cour d'assises
spéciale de paris
les 14 accusés présents vont s'exprimer
dans le cadre des interrogatoires de
personnalité avec les éléments
biographiques leur parcours d'enfance et
de jeunesse et ses salles abdeslam qui a
parlé en premier depuis l'ouverture du
procès il s'est montré très véhément se
revendiquant combattants de l'état
islamique mais aujourd'hui il soigne son
image avec un discours très policée à
voix basse en gilet chemise grise avec
les cheveux ras et une barbe foisonnante
qui témoigne de sa ferveur religieuse
alors il a décrit à voix basse une
enfance sans histoire une bonne ambiance
familiale l'obtention d'un bac technique
n'était plutôt studieux il a exercé
quelques métier réparateur de trains
intérimaire il était aussi gérant du bar
en 2014 de son frère brahim un des
tueurs des terrasses avec un parcours de
petite délinquance qu'il réfute des
amendes des excès de vitesse mais aussi
une tentative de cambriolage en 2010
avec abdelhamid abou oud un des tueurs
des terrasses son ami d'enfance
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le moment du
procès d'aborder la radicalisation mais
sa croyance est toujours aussi forte par
exemple il a traité ces surveillants
déjà de mécréants en réaction à cet
interrogatoire je vous propose d'écouter
m jean reinhart avocat des parties
civiles nous sommes face à mon avis un
personnes une personne intelligente qui
est assez qu'est caméléon elle a compris
que l'agressivité dont elle avait fait
preuve au tout début des déclarations
intempestives qui tombait à plat n'avait
plus lieu d'être et c'est pour cela que
je crois que il a changé son disque
alors le basculement alors là c'est le
point d'interrogation parce que là nous
avons tous les éléments qui sont
contraires à ce basculement donc ça fait
intéressant un jour de comprendre
pourquoi il a basculé de quelle façon et
avec qui voilà ça ce sera pour plus tard
l'accusé mohamed à brégnias parlait
également aujourd'hui c'est l'ancien
voisin de salles abdeslam à molenbeek il
est accusé de l'avoir conduit le 11
novembre 1015 il était présent à
l'aéroport de bruxelles le 26 mars 2016
dans des attentats c'est l'homme au
chapeau après un échec scolaire et
chaque en club de foot il a fait de
nombreux allers retours en prison il
avait une addiction casino qui était
financé avec l'argent des vols quinze
années de criminalité sans violence at
il précisé autres accusés il ya six
natale frère du cerveau des attentats
djihadistes présumés morts en syrie
oussama atar et puis également attendues
aujourd'hui fabrique arcache accusé
d'avoir fourni des faux papiers qui ont
permis à des djihadistes de venir en
europe en partant de la syrie